or turning on the lights tonight the
neon Museum debuts another glittering
part of Las Vegas's past now the neon
museum is adding an old sign to its
Boneyard near downtown it's going to
have new life again and soon we can all
see it Lauren negretti has a sneak peek
at the Lido de parisan back in Action
good morning Lauren can't wait to see it
you and me both yes good morning yes
after nearly two decades of inactivity
the leader of the parade will be once
again illuminated here in Las Vegas with
me I've got Aaron Berger talking about
it with the museum so talk to me this
was a long time come in tell me about
the restoration process so this is two
decades that this this sign has been
sitting in our collection and it is now
being brought back to its beauty and
Glory tonight I'm so excited wonderful
yeah and you know this was like you said
a special partnership you had here with
a gift a gift exactly Todd Von bastions
was a uh is a lighting professional and
has done so many of the shows that we
see in Las Vegas and he wanted to find a
way to pay tribute to the people who
have really made the entertainment
capital of the world what it is so he's
focused on those people behind the
curtain so you know we have Adele we
have Katy Perry we have these amazing
residencies here but we have so many
behind the curtain that aren't given
their due attention and this is his
tribute to them which I love
not really sharing the spotlight exactly
putting that Spotlight on those people
and as well no that sounds perfect and
again this is it's going to be great
event 250 people gonna be here
sandwiched together exactly cold tonight
yes exactly um but even though you know
it is uh sold out the event is sold out
but you know the good thing is that you
know people can share their stories to
to you guys as well of belito any
pictures that they have and going
forward you know from from after tonight
going forward the Lido will once again
be re-illuminated here in Las Vegas
looking forward to it thank you so much
it's going to be such a great night
perfect for now live at the neon Museum
Lauren negretti 8 News Now